[Musique]
oh
si je vous donnais à choisir entre ce
que vous voulez
ou ce qui est comprenez quoi
entre l'image d'une crème à la glace est
une vraie crème à la glace
entre
un bonheur éphémère
l'enthousiaste
qu'est-ce que vous choisissez
cet enthousiasme c'est pas quelque chose
mr c'est comme un carburant non m 10 et
sur le pétrole et pour lequel on
descendra pas dans la rue pour dire non
à la hausse des prix parce que c'est
gratuit
ces deux données
or comment l'exprimer cet enthousiasme
l'iran soit au delà de tout ce qu'on
veut
quelle est la clé
expression là
voir ensemble auquel on va s'exercer
science et exprime au père sortir avec
force avec vitalité
et dans nos quotidiens on connaît
l'expression pour convaincre pour
persuader l'art d'avoir raison ce serait
l'art d'être vrai authentique soi même
hier
ce serait sortir d'une situation
difficile dans laquelle on est ou alors
passer d'un point a à un point b
on appelle ça réussir à voir quelque
chose
un peu comme une allumette qu'on craque
vous savez je vais une nouvelle voiture
un nouveau couple je veux quelque chose
de nouveau
je craque l'allumette l'allumette
s'éteint
même si je mets ma vie au milieu toute
la boîte d'allumettes
et bien même elle elle s'éteint dans
cent ans plus ou moins tous les gens qui
sont dans cette salle même ceux qui
regardent la télé ne seront plus là
nous sommes égaux face à la mort
alors c'est très enthousiasmant on va
voir c'est un jeu d'enfant mes amis
parce que l'enfant il a la particularité
d'être un véritable bosse pour ça il n'a
pas toutes ses allumettes à craquer
nouvelle voiture à acheter un nouveau
travail et cetera donc
on va laisser de côté
ce qu'on a dans la tête et on va vider à
de goni on va vider notre sac libérer
notre cerveau d'accord
vous connaissez l'expression goni du
vide il n'y a pas de doute voilà
et moi je dis connu de vide il a la
place pour contenir la grâce c'est mon
point de vue donc bidon enlevant tous
les livres qu'on a écrit ou qu'on a lui
enlevant aux urgences enlevons toutes
nos allumettes qu'on aurait eu pour
toute une vie
même les plus précieuses même si on est
la plus belle des villas de toute façon
on devrait la quitter mettons de côté un
instant le temps avec lequel la vie
parfois difficile mettons de côté toutes
nos revendications
le ton de côté nos maîtres mettant de
côté tous bourroux ne croyant à rien
soyons sceptiques et commençons
enfin il est conditionné à partir d'un
certain âge l'enfant à partir de ces
premiers date d'anniversaire
après qu'eric
elles cinq civils et autres il apprend à
vouloir on lui demande de faire des
listes vont vouloir demander peut
demander une pizza par exemple et de
vouloir vouloir donc pour vous le
vraiment
le terran témoigner j'ai pris l'histoire
d'un jeune enfant ici
la plaie l'humanité si vous vouliez bien
parce qu'on est tous les enfants de
l'humanité et cet enfant a une histoire
ou son enthousiasme s'exprime on a tous
un enfant il est né en iran
il sait pas qu'il est né dans un pays
qui vient de vivre une guerre de huit
ans avec l'irak ni même une révolution
qui a changé son régime
à l'âge de 4 ans il est témoin de
quelque chose qui va pour la première
fois et veiller son enthousiasme dans la
salle qui le sépare de sa salle
d'entraînement parce que son corps est
un nid de souffrance il est malade il
sait pas pourquoi
toute la famille a peur toute la famille
a des attentes
tout le monde fait des promesses
d'ailleurs qu'on voyait sur la photo
c'est un lieu de beaucoup de promesses
et d'attentes et bien le médecin va
annoncer à ses parents que votre enfant
bas il va mourir à l'âge de 8 ans plus
ou moins alors qu'il s'arrête de
s'entraîner et il profite de la vie
rés
attentes de toutes ces peurs
peillon lui un enthousiasme une vitalité
extraordinaire il fait qu'il va
s'entraîner avec amour
avec attention
avec plus d'affection
un peu
à
à la maternelle il rencontre une jeune
fille appelée nirvana qu'il invite dans
un autre type d'école une école de la
connaissance
on apprend à être soi et du fond de la
salle où il regarde entre la fente du
rideau et voit un homme qui parle
et sa vibration de savoie vient le
marque l'apaiser le tranquilliser
il va prendre conscience d'un certain
amour d'une attention particulière d'une
affection qui n'est pas dix cibles qui
ne peut pas être exprimés mais qui est
présent cependant cet homme ces adresses
à l'oeil du na li no des chars encore
vous allez voir le site existe mtl.org
histoire vraie
un peu plus tard dans sa vie dans la
même maternelle il va rencontrer le
premier enfant noir qui l'a jamais vu de
tout ça vieillit en iran il n'en avait
pas vu
il va aller voir cet ami et il va lui
frotter le visage veut dire mais il faut
dire à tes parents te laver
et là c'est un scandale mais la mère de
l'humanité qui est ici n'a pas le
gronder elle va prendre pour nous une
dame camerounaise
l'humanité se retrouve chez cette dame
est il la voit prendre soin de ses cinq
enfants avoir de l'affection pour eux
les embrasser les câliner les cajoler et
puis un soir il arrive que sa mère
rentre fatigué pour venir le chercher et
il entend une conversation toujours
depuis derrière une porte s est forte
elle toujours là c'est entre les deux
battants quand l'enfant regarde vous
voyez ben ils étaient moins d'une chose
sa mère de l'humanité ni à la marque
camerounaise comment est-ce qui va elle
lui répond
il arrive toujours pas se faire toucher
mais ils commencent à nous parler hélas
à la mer d'humanité fond en larmes et
elle dit je n'ai pas réussi
un peu plus tard dans sa vie cet enfant
cette humanité va découvrir c'est quoi
être étranger ils arrivent à l'âge de 4
ans et à partir de 18 ans on lui demande
d'aller chercher une carte de séjour il
se sent un peu humilié et pour lui c'est
une épreuve dont il a une attente la
tente d'avoir la carte de séjour et dans
la file d'attenté
il fait une rencontre
laurine dames africaines elle a un
enfant et filles à note dans la
poussette
l'humanité il dit la peine pour vous il
est 6 heures du matin on va passer à 10
heures sinon honte
et adam africain lui répondant c'est
pour toi de la panne
ce que tu vas devoir attendre jusqu'à
10h01 amenés à manger est pas rien
n'avait pourtant soit dans la poussette
il ya une pomme prend bien tabouret
francs et alors l'humanité ça soit ils
mangent cette pomme tout en écoutant
l'histoire de cette femme est au bout de
son histoire et lui dit tu vois après
tout ce que j'ai vécu je suis prêt à
attendre des dizaines d'heures s'il le
faut mais jamais sans mon sourire
alors
forme qui le sépare des barrières vous
savez de l'entrée d'une préfecture
la même une même une amène des humanités
voit le slogan de la france
égalité fraternité
liberté n'est ce pas
il se dit merci marianne merci la france
merci madame
la pomme pour la
section pour la tension et ça c'est dans
de diass
sa vie cet enfant va apprendre à
entreprendre vous savez entreprendre
prendre entre c'est à dire entre l'air
l'espace qui est bouché l'air
l'entrepreneur à mettre une cigarette
offrant une valeur ajoutée entre
l'espace y est entre tes yeux vont voir
le monde et en profiter il va mettre un
téléphone un smartphone l'entreprend et
puis il va entreprendre il va avoir une
belle réussite
la première fois qu'il va faire faillite
il a passé d'entrepreneur à restos du
coeur alors que pour la première fois on
lui avait donné quelque chose de gratuit
de la nourriture gratuitement
il voit toujours à travers les mots
forts un acte d'amour
rien d'autre
sans rien attendre en retour
elle
or son cerveau a complètement retourné
chose qui cloche
et il rentre en tête
il bat st
et partout
que les religions
il va même arrivé à apprendre la bible
le coran le la torah tout les types de
relier gens et a même peut-être même se
faire baptiser à la veille de son
baptême un ami chrétien lui remet un
livre sur lequel il ya écrit jésus
contre mahomet toute la nuit manière ce
livre me au lieu de ressentir une
division
il va sentir de l'amour avis il faut que
je le dise mais il savait que ce point
de vue là allez peut-être blessé celui
qui avait passé plus d'un an a lieu à
enseigner
toutes les lois qu'il avait apprise
jusqu'ici
alors qu'elle était devant lui
annie cette chose son regard s'est
tourné vers le jardin
la vie ce qui est cette beauté cet amour
enthousiaste
il a donné
pour peu de gens
peuvent véritablement ressentir vous
savez ça le semble division alors le
presque lui a dit je peux pas votre
crise est élu il ya des juges totalement
d'accord avec son point de vue mais
sache que je t'aime je vais reprendre
mon chemin
et il a rencontré un maître bouddhiste
zen contemporain de martin luther king
johnatan lui a dit tu vois le monde
quitte en bateau dehors
fière de toi ne cherche pas
là et bien là et j'attends lui tu vois
si ton poumon tombe malade est ce que tu
vas arracher son poumon et le jeter non
tu va l'accepter l'accueillir comprend
qu'il est malade en prendre soin lui
donner de l'attention de l'amour de la
bienveillance assez une porte à nouveau
qui s'ouvre pour lui cet enfant voyez
vous avez beaucoup d'autres aventures
depuis il a rencontré beaucoup d'autres
personnes dont une femme un doux qui l'a
invité à la réunion
et grâce à l'amour de laquelle il peut
aujourd'hui s'exprimer en face de vous
donc je vous prie de l'applaudir et la
rime
voilà il est là bas il fat il est là
[Rires]
chers amis après toutes ces preuves
d'amour auquel on assiste
combien ça nous coûte la peur première
année au coude la tente comment ça nous
coûte les promesses
j'avais sur le site du ministère voire
aux vendeuses impôts ça vous pouvez
allez tout le monde paye allez yallah
passeur mais impots.gouv.fr que sur 1000
euros d'impôts qu'on paie il ya 200
euros qui vont payer des armes et des
gendarmes
quand on veut tuer tuer quelqu'un avec
une arme ont créé une arme on la tue
est-ce qu'on peut tuer la peur on en a
trop bas
mais que là
question d'une mère
peut apaiser cette peur
à l'école est ce qu'on apprend plus à
aller vers ce qu'on veut ou alors plutôt
à aimer
est ce qu'on apprend à avoir de la
compétition avec l'hôte à se comparer ou
alors est ce que on apprend avoir de
l'attention de l'affection pour l'autre
tout cela peut-être changer si nous
changeons de paradigme si nous modifions
notre façon de fonctionner toujours de
mon point de vue en haut nous avons une
première façon qui est de ce que je veux
et pourquoi je le veux ici même tapis
rouge saimone et il a dit que apple
connaissons pourquoi et c'est pour ça qu
apple a réussi jeudi apple a réussi pour
son budget marketing et pour avoir pu
susciter de l'attendre et de vendre ou
tous ces produits et que le paradigme
qui pourrait changer radicalement nos
manières de fonctionner ce que nous
sommes c'est tout si ce n'est pas légaux
qui nous dirigent de la même veine
hier aylesworth trading les idées qui
méritent d'être une prendre extension
d'être partagée ici on va d'un point a à
un point b
quelque part on est pauvre et on devient
riche ici on va d'un point à un point à
plus élevé plus d'attention plus
d'affection de l'amour c'est l'école de
la vie à l'école dans laquelle nous
sommes
qui à travers chaque expérience nous
apprend et à plus être là ici et
maintenant
et pour terminer
peut-être que tout cela n'est rien
parce qu'aujourd'hui on vient des queues
de s'exercer à cet enthousiasme cette
expression là et peut-être que tout cela
n'est rien et prenez rien l'homme étant
une poussière sur la terre et la terre
étant une poussière dans l'univers
depuis quand est-ce qu'on se croient
importants
au 20ème siècle l'être humain a tué plus
d'hommes que la nature 300 fois plus si
on faisait une minute de silence dans ce
siècle pour chaque mort qu'il y a eu
nous aurions un demi-millénaire de
silence de paix
propose un nouveau rituel de tedx pour
les chacun de tedx c'est tel que nous le
dit
havre a toujours max adhérents grand
temps que ton ego est avec toi vaniteux
tuer tout à l'adoration de toi même ivre
de tout entier de ton ignorance
tu n'es rien moins que rien c'est dieu
qui tuent à libérer et de lego ou tuer
tous si tu veux tout ce que tu veux
danton goni
ces comptes il est vide en tête
s'exprimer l'amour sais pas comment on
peut communiquer plus d'attention
je vous invite
que vous soyez vous soyez de partout
dans le monde à prendre ce temps un
instant
le temps nous manque c'est ce qu'on
pense
on tient nos coeurs
il écouté ce champ
en
tout est parti à métaux asbo halo reach
mastic à métaux
[Musique]
ichigo et kitsch comme tu as dit aux
petits fruits d'aunis au pays
[Musique]
torres et un métro
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]